dos investigaciones en marcha con
repercusiones potencialmente dañinas
para el presidente francés la fiscalía
de París anunció que había iniciado
investigaciones sobre el uso y
contratación de consultoras de gestión
durante la campaña presidencial de 2017
al igual que la de 2022 aunque no se
menciona por su nombre se cree que
Manuel macón y sus vínculos con la
empresa estadounidense Mackenzie son uno
de los focos de las pesquisas los
vínculos de la empresa con el presidente
han sido criticados desde hace tiempo
las investigaciones se centrarán en las
acusaciones de posible falsificación de
la contabilidad de la campaña electoral
y de infravaloración de sus gastos así
como de posible favoritismo el gobierno
solo se limitó a reconocer las
investigaciones
el Eliseo toma nota de la apertura de
las dos investigaciones judiciales se
indica también que corresponde a la
justicia llevar a cabo estas
investigaciones con total Independencia
el uso de consultorías se puso en el
punto de mira en marzo tras una
investigación del senado francés que
concluyó que el gasto público alcanzó
más de mil millones de euros solo en
consultoras el año pasado y se produce
en medio de las denuncias de que
consultores del grupo estadounidense
Mackenzie trabajaron gratis en la
campaña de macron de 2017 Francia tiene
normas estrictas sobre la financiación
de las campañas que ponen límites a lo
que un candidato puede gastar varios
políticos franceses han sido
investigados a lo largo de los años
justo por gastar en exceso como el
presidente Nicolás sarkozy que en
septiembre del año pasado fue condenado
a un año de prisión por la financiación
ilegal de su candidatura a la reelección
en 2012